uh jody returns us villanelle it's
coming soon to the bbc we can say no
more
soon soon
uh now the stats of this amazing the box
set on iplayer every episode was watched
by an average of six million people i
mean what was that like coming back to
series two being on set knowing this is
an enormous hit now nerve-wracking
was it more pressure was it more fun no
i i think there is pressure because
there's so much expectation like before
it everyone was kind of like killing
what like what is this new show and now
it's like you know everyone's kind of
waiting on tender hugs for it to come
out but i think once you start filming
you kind of just have
to put it to one side but when we
started filming series two and we were
filming on the street and it was out
here at the time and there was just
crowds of people on the street and i
think that's when we realized oh
we should probably heighten the security
[Laughter]
yeah
and so what can you tell us about
serious turks it starts
30 seconds after
the premier yeah episode is amazing
because i've already seen it yeah and i
don't want to ruin anything don't
okay
that one bit with the teenage boy yeah
yeah
that is amazing i see that coming did
you know no i did not see that coming
and the whole thing that villanelle
because she is this is quite an extreme
character presumably you get extreme
reactions from fans and things when you
when you meet people in the street yeah
i mean
a lot of people just look at me and
think is it hair but i had one recently
that was really strange someone asked me
um for a photograph and i was like yeah
sure and was um posing for a photograph
and then she quietly just whispered in
my ear
will you strangle
and i me like
oh
and my brother sisters went the other
time and she was like no
miss comey will not do that no jody was
that betty she does
[Music]
you